اتفقت اطراف الاتفاق الايطالي للعمليه
السياسيه في السودان على مهله خمسه ايام
لحل القضايا الخلافيه التي اخرت التوقيع
على الاتفاق النهائي الذي كان مقررا يوم
السبت وقال المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه
ان القرار اتخذ بالاجماع خلال اجتماع حضره
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وبقيه
الاطراف المعنيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما فحوى واسباب
الخلافه الذي عطل توقيع الاتفاق النهائي
في السودان وما امكانيه تجاوزه خلال
المهله المتفق عليها ما دلالات تعثر
التوافق على دمج واصلاح المكونات المسلحه
في هذه المرحله ومنعكاس ذلك على مستقبل
تشكيل هياكل الحكم برمتها وعلى اي نحو
تنظر القوى المدنيه المتفقه والمختلفه مع
مسار العمليه السياسيه لهذه الخلافات وما
انعكاسات تجاوزها على مستقبل الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
بعد خلافات حالت دون التوصل الى توصيات في
نهايه ورشه الاصلاح والدمج في القطاع
الامني والعسكري التي اختتمت اعمالها
الاربعاء الماضيه واهمها بحسب مصادر
الخلاف بشان توقيت دمج قوات السريع الدعم
السريع في الجيش اعلن المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان اتفاق اطراف
الاتفاق الايطالي للعمليه السياسيه على
مهله مدتها خمسه ايام تضاعف خلالها الجهود
او تتضاعف لحل القضايا الخلافيه التي حالت
دون توقيع ذلك الاتفاق الذي كان مقررا
سبته قرار ارجاء التوقيع على الاتفاق
النهائي اتخذ بحسب المتحدث بالاجماع في
اجتماع ان عقد بالقصر الجمهوري وشارك فيها
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وبقيه اطراف
العمليه السياسيه من المدنيين والاليه
ثلاثيه المسيره لها والمكونه من الاتحاد
الافريقي ومنظمه والامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
السيد طاهر المعتصم الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي والنور احمد النور الكاتب الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي ابدا معك سيد طاهر سيد
طاهر موعد 6 ابريل هل هو موعد نهائي او هو
مرتبط بحل الخلافات العالقه الى حد الان
مساء الخير عليك وعلى مشاهديكي وعلى ضيفك
الكريم
يبدو ان 6 ابريل ليس لن يكون المنتهى
المتوقعه للتوقيع النهائي اذ ان الخلاف
الواضح حتى الان
لم يصل فيه الطرفان الى
التغارب في وجهات النظر وهو الخلاف حول
دمج وتحديث الدعم السريع
وضموا للقوات المسلحه السودانيه هذا الامر
بعد انقطاع الورشه نعم هذه المهله خمسه
ايام
اعطيت خمس ايام بناء على معطيات متوفره
امام المجتمعون اليوم وهذا بحسب معلوماتنا
اقتراح تقدم به رئيس مجلس السياده قائد
الجيش
بان يكون موعد الاتفاق في السادس من ابريل
وفقا لمعطيات وفرات اللجنه الفنيه التي
تناقش الاطراف ما بين الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه
لمواقيت الدمج وبدايه بدايه هذا الدمش
المعطيات التي اتت من اللجنه هي المبرر ما
هي هذه المعطيات باختصار لو سمحت
المعطيات ان الفترات الزمنيه التي تقدمت
بها كل جهه الجيش تقدم بحسب المعلومات
بفتره زمنيه لا تتعدل عامين
ودعم السريع يطالب بفتره زمنيه اطول حوالي
10 سنوات
النقاش حول هذه اللقطه تحديدا ومتى يبدا
الدمج هو موضع الخلاف
الفنيين من الجهتين يحاولون تغريب وجهات
النظر للوصول الى محطه وسطى
ساعود معك ولكن دعني اسمع من السيده النور
احمد النور سيد النور لطالما كان التعاطي
مع المكون العسكري على انه مكون واحد وحده
حال ما الذي ادى الى الخلافات في الفتره
الاخيره
ان الخلافات منشاها خلاف سياسي في
التقديرات السياسيه بين قياده الجيش
وقياده الدعم السريع وليس خلافات فنيه في
القضايا الدمج فقط لذلك اعتقد ان الايام
الست المحدده او الخمسه ايام لمعالجه هذه
القضايا العاليه تحتاج الى قرار سياسي
وليس قرار فني كونه مده دمج متى تبدا فتره
الدمج وتنتهي هذا قرار سياسي متى يتوقع ان
يتوقف الجامعه السريع عن التجنيد عن اقامه
المعسكرات عن التسليح هذه قرارات تحتاج
الى يعني مواقف تحتاج الى قرارات سياسيه
من غير طرفين يمكن معالجتها في خلال خمس
ساعات فقط اذا توفرت الاراده السياسيه
ولكن اعتقد ان هناك ازمه ثقه بين الطرفين
تحتاج لمعالجات
محله انا اسال كيف نشا هذا الخلاف ما هو
سر الانقلاب لطالما كان الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في خندق واحد يدافعون عن بعض هما
البعض ولكن ما شاهدناه في الايام الاخيره
هو ظهور خلافات بين الجانبين الى العلن
وكانهما
شقين وليس شق واحد ما الذي جاره
الخلاف هو خلاف سياسي بين غيادين الطرفين
الدعم السريع انحاز الى تحالف هو الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي وصار جزءا من هذا
التحالف بينما يرى الجيش بريبه الى هذا
التحالف باعتبار ان بعد اطرافه تنادي علنا
بتفكيك الجيش السوداني وتحويل قوات الدعم
السريع الى نوال الجيش يعني تفكيك الجيش
ويحل محله الدعم السريع ويكون هو نوال
الجيش القومي الوطني واعتقد ان ذلك ايضا
سباق حول التحالفات السياسيه في المرحله
المقبله كيف لقوها عسكريه تيار سياسي
يستنصر بقوه عسكريه خلال هذه الفتره على
قوه اخرى اعتقد هذا هو اسباب الكلام
الرئيسيه من السيد طاهر المعتصم
الدعم السريع في الفتره الاخيره او منذ
الخامس من ديسمبر عند توقيع الاتفاق
الاطاري
الى جانب التحول المدني الديمقراطي اكد
على خروجهم كمؤسسه عسكريه من العمليه
السياسيه
اصرار على هذا الامر هو يدفع ثمنه الان
كانه اصبح يزايد على الجيش فيه في المواقف
الخاصه بالتحول المدني الديمقراطي مناداه
الدعم السريع بهذا الامر وتحولات الكبرى
مؤكده انها مصدر ريبه كما قال استاذ النور
لدى القوات المسلحه السودانيه لان الدعم
السريع قرر ان يتجه الى الكتله المدنيه
وان ينادي بخروج المواسطه العسكريه تماما
الى جانب قوى الحريه والتغيير يعني هل هذا
ما يقوم او تقوم به قوات الدعم السريع
لا ليس بهذا المعنى ولكن الدعم السريع بعد
ان بعد ان راجع فتره فطرته منذ الخامس
والعشرين ملك اكتوبر 2021
وجد ان العمليه التي قامت عمليه الانقلاب
العسكري على المؤسسات الدستوريه ووضع رئيس
الوزراء وقتها قيد الاقامه الجبريه وجد
انه الخاسر الاكبر خلال هذه الفتره اذ ان
النظام السابق عاد بقوه الى المشهد
السياسي
والدعم السريع وجد ان الامر لم يفضي الى
توقعاته التي بنى عليها موقفه بدعم 25
اكتوبر
قرر اعاده الموضوع وغرر ان يكون نصيرا
للخروج من العمليه السياسيه هذا الامر هو
الذي سبب هواجس لدى القوات المسلحه
السودانيه طيب اعود اليك سيد النور احمد
النور يعني هل يعني ذلك بان الجيش لا يقف
الى جانب من وقع معهم على الاتفاق
الايطالي هل يعني ذلك بان هنالك داخل قوى
الحريه والتغيير ما يطالب بتفكيك الجيش
نعم هناك من يناديق الجيش على انه هذا ليس
امرا سرا ولكن الان المواقف السياسيه باتت
قريبه بين الدعم السريع وقوه التحالف هو
الحريه والتغيير التي يرى الجيش انها تريد
ان تستنصر بالدعم السريع لمواجهه الجيش او
لتفكيك الجيش بمعنى اخر لذلك اعتقد هذه
الاسباب الرئيسيه للخلاف ولكن يمكن معالجه
هذا الخلاف اذا توفرت النوايا الحسنه واذا
توفرت الاراده السياسيه للطرفين طيب سيدنا
النور احمد النوري ولكن الم يوقع الجيش
على الاتفاق الا يعني التوقيع عليه بانه
ملتزم به
نعم هو حتى اليوم حتى اول امس اصدر الجيش
بيان ملتزم بهذا الاتفاق ولكن المشكله ليس
في الاتفاق الاتفاق هذه احد تحدياته فقط
قضيه الدمج الدعم السريع ولكن هناك كثير
من التحديات التي تواجه هذا الاتفاق حتى
الان كثيرون في المؤسسه العسكريه يعتقدون
ان هذا
النور
سياسيه محدوده اذا كان الامر كذلك واذا
كان الجيش ملتزم بالاتفاق الذي تم توقيع
عليه لماذا اذا يعني تقوم قوى الحريه
والتغيير بالاستناد او بمحاوله استماله
قوات الدمج الشريعه او لماذا من الاساس
تحتاج قوات الدعم السريع الى الانحياز الى
جانب قوى الحريه والتغيير كما ذكرتم
هو الحريه والتغيير تعتقد ان قائد الجيش
هو الذي قام بانقلاب 25 اكتوبر ضد واقصها
من السلطه ولذلك لا تثق فيه الان تريد ان
تستقوي بقوات الدعم السريع لاي خطوات
سياسيه مقبله في مقبله الايام وليس حاليا
وبالتالي كلها تتعلق بالنوايا وازمه الثقه
بين الطرفين طيب اسمع رد من السيد الطاهر
المعتصم على هذه النقطه يعني سيد الطاهر
المعتصم قوي الحريه والتغيير هي من وقعت
الاتفاق مع الجيش الحديث عن من قام
بالانقلاب الم تتجاوزه الاحداث اليوم في
السودان
تجاوزته تماما بدليل ان الورش والمؤتمرات
الخمسه القضايا المرحله من الاتفاق
الاطاري
وتحديدا ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
خاطبها قائد الجيش السوداني وابدا ترحابوا
بهذه العمليه ودعمه لها وكانت خلال
الاربعه ايام المؤسسه العسكريه
ممثليها موجودين في هذه الورشه وتعاطوا
بشكل ايجابي في هذا الامر ولكن الغش التي
قسمت ظهر البعير هي مزعله دمج الدعم
السريع
ومواقيت الزمنيه ومتى تبدا
ومحاولات لاذابه الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه السودانيه في خلفيه تاريخيه سريعه
الدعم السريع كان تابع للقوات المسلحه في
يوليو 2019 قرر قائد الجيش عدم تبعيته
بمرسوم للقوات المسلحه المدنيين الان غير
معنيين
بان القوات الدمج السريع انحازت لقوى
الحريه والتغيير لماذا تنحاز قوات الدمج
السريع للحريه والتغيير اذا كان الجيش
ملتزما بتطبيق الاتفاق
هنا كان السؤال هي لم هي لم تنحاز ولكن
تغاربت مواقفها في المطالبه بالتحول
المدني الديمقراطي وبخروج المؤسسه
العسكريه
اعاده التموضع للدعم السريع جعل مواقف
متغاربه مع قوى الحريه والتغيير والقوى
الموقعه للاتفاق على الاطاري ليس تحالف هو
ولكن وحدتهم المواقف بعد تجربه حوالي
انقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر
طيب
اعود اليك سيد النور احمد النور سيد النور
احمد النور ان اليوم هنالك مهله خمسه ايام
هذه المهله شككتم فيها وذكرتم بان الموضوع
يحتاج الى قرار سياسي في حال لم تحل هذه
الخلافات في الايام الخمسه المقبله ما
مصير الاتفاق
كل هذا تحليل هذا تحليل انا وليس معلومات
حول اي خطوات مقبله ولكن الموضوع الامر
الموضوعي المنطقه الموضوع يقول ذلك انه
اذا تباعدت مواقف الاطراف وتعذر حل هذه
المشاكل فانه لا يمكن ان تستمر الازمه الى
ما لا نهايه وبالتالي لا ينبغي ان تشكل
الحكومه التصريفه اعمال تقود البلاد الى
انتخابات مبكره قبل موعد
سيد طاهر تشكيل حكومه تصريف اعمال هل هذا
وارد في حال لم يتم حل الخلافات خلال
الايام الخمسه المقبله ما مصير الاتفاق
النهائي
قد يتاجل التوقيع ولكن هناك قوه دفع دوليه
كبيره
للوصول الى نهايات هذا الاتفاق
مازالت حكومه تصريفه اعمال لم تنجح السلطه
السلطه الامر الواقع في تشكيله منذ 25 من
اكتوبر 2021 حتى الان لا يوجد رئيس وزراء
في السودان لا توجد حكومه كلهم مكلفين
وزراء مكلفين
اضافه الى ان نزلت تصريف اعمال واجراء
انتخابات في ظل عدم وجود تعداد سكاني في
ظل وجود نازحين في المعسكرات في ظل
الانفلات الامنيه الكبيره تصبح في غايه
الخطوره في ظل وجود ثمانيه جيوش لم تضمهم
الترتيبات الامنيه انا اتفق مع استاذ
النور في ان المساله ليس مساله الدمج فقط
للدعم السريع ولكن المشهد ككل السياسي
يحتاج الى اختراق اكبر قد يكون الان
النقاش حول الامور الف نيه لدمج الدعم
السريع ولكن هناك اخرين في حركه العدل
والمساواه والجيش تحرير السودان وغيرهم
مطلوب ان يكونوا شركاء في العمليه
السياسيه عدم حضور حتى الان يصبح يهدد
للعمليه السياسيه
ذكر هؤلاء الان يعني لماذا لم يتم الحديث
عن هؤلاء والعمل على اشراكهم قبل توقيع
الاتفاق والعمل على الاتفاق النهائي يعني
لماذا يتم الحديث بشكل مكثف عن المكونات
التي لم تشارك في هذه العمليه الان وليس
من البدايه
لا منذ اللحظه الاولى منذ اول الاجتماعات
قبل الوصول الى الاتفاق الايطالي يتم
التشاور والاجتماعات السريه والاجتماعات
غير الرسميه مع هذه الاطراف وهناك محاولات
لضمها لم تتوقف حتى هذه الايام
بالتالي هذا الامر ليس جديد وهي واحده من
التهديدات للحكومه القادمه
وقوى الحريه والتغيير والموقعين على
الاتفاق الاطار بازلوا جهود في ضم هؤلاء
الى هذا الاتفاق طيب من المقصود بهؤلاء
قوه جيش تحرير السودان بقياده مناوي الجيش
حركه تحرير العدل والمساواه الحزب
الاتحادي جناح جعفر المرغني دكتور التجاني
السيسي ومجموعته مجموعات موجوده
السيد مناوي حاكم اقليم دار والسيد جبريل
الماليه ولديهم سبع وزراء يعني من يمكن ان
يضم ايضا الى هذه الى هذه الحوارات وهنا
اعود الى السيد نور سيد نور ذكرت ضروره
تعميق الحوار ليشمل قضايا سياسيه اخرى عن
اي قضايا سياسيه تتحدثون
نتحدث عن ان هناك قوه رئيسيه وهو فاعله في
المشهد السياسي غائبه عن هذا الاتفاق هذا
الاتفاق الان يعبر عن ثلاثه تنظيمات هي
التحالف تغيير المجلس المركزي الان هناك
هو التغيير الجزري لحزب الشيوعي والقوه
اليسار والتجمعات المدنيه وتجمع المهنيين
واللجان
الاحياء لجان المقاومه وهناك التيار
الاسلامي العريض الذي يضم التيارات
الاسلاميه والسلفيه وهناك القوه الكتله
الديمقراطيه التي تضم حركات مسلحه وتضم
الحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي وتدوم قوه من
شرق السودان وغربي وهناك تيارات اخرى
وبالتالي غائبه هذا الاتفاق هذا المطلب
واقعيا هل يمكن وضع كل هذه التيارات في
سله واحده يعني هي مختلفه ايديولوجيا
ومختلفه عقائديا هل يمكن ذلك الا يبدو ذلك
ضربا من الخيال ومزيد من الوقت وصرف مزيد
من الوقت على الحوارات ومناقشات
ليس بالضروره ان يكون هناك اجماع بكل هذه
القوى ولكن يكون هناك توافق بين سبعين الى
ثمانين في المئه هذه القوه الان الذين
توافقوا لا يشكلون نحو الا نحو 30% البقيه
الان تم اغصاء الباقيه والان هم سيكونوا
الرصيد معارض للحكومه المقبله والحكومه
الاولى ستكون اذا تشكلت بهذه القوه فقط
ستكون حكومه هشه ولا اعتقد انه يمكن ان
تستمر اكثر من سته اشهر ستسقط هذه الحكومه
لانه هناك اليوم تم اغلاق شرق السودان
والاداره الاهليه في الولايه الخرطوم قالت
انها يوم الاربعاء المقبل وبالتالي هناك
معارضه واسعه لهذه الحكومه ما لم يحصل
توافق وطني كبير في المرحله المقبل اسمع
من السيد طاهر سيد طاهر هنالك من
يتمنعون عن المشاركه فيما يتعلق بتوسيع
هذا الاتفاق بالتالي هل يمكن للسودان ان
ينتظر هؤلاء الى ان يوافقوا وما هي نظره
القوى السياسيه لظهور هذه الخلافات بين
المكون العسكري على السطح باختصار لو سمحت
القوه الواقعه الاتفاق الاطاري بما فيها
قوى الحريه والتغيير
اعطت وما صبغه شيء في سبيل الوصول الى هذا
الاتفاق الان المشكله الظاهره امامهم هي
خلاف ما بين الجيش والدعم السريع
مساله الاطراف الاخرى الواجب وصوله وهي
تتعنت حتى الان هناك مراحل اخرى من
الاتفاق النهائي وتشكيل الهياكل المدنيه
يمكن ان يشاركوا فيها شكرا لك سيد طاهر
المعتصم الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
والشكر موصول للسيد النور احمد النور
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
بهذا تصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]